it really shocked me this primal urge I
had it shocked me and it hurt me I did
seek help Liam Neeson is under fire
after making controversial comments on
race and revenge gonna kill him
while Liam was promoting his new film
cold pursuit a movie about revenge he
told a reporter about an incident where
his friend was allegedly raped by a
black person now get this Liam admits he
contemplated carrying out a racist hate
attack the actor recalled the incident
telling Britain's independent quote I
went up and down areas with the coach a
club hoping I'd be approached by
somebody I'm ashamed to say that and I
did it for maybe a week hoping some
quote black bastard would come out of a
pub and have a go at me about something
you know so that I could kill him now
obviously his exact words were not taken
lightly fans took to Twitter calling
Liam a performative racist and that he
quote publicly admitted he's racist I
went to a barista there my confession
I was really Catholic at two very very
good friends that they talked to and
believe it or not power of walking power
yeah two hours every day I'm not racist
after all that backlash Liam appear on
Good Morning America where he clarified
his comments recounting the story again
on air I'd never felt this feeling
before which was a primal urge to lash
out she said he was a black man I
thought okay
and after that there were some nights
I've annoyed deliberately into black
areas in this city looking to be set
upon so that I could unleash physical
violence
now despite making some jarring comments
I do appreciate how he cleared things up
quickly and Liam didn't retract or
sugarcoat his story he did admit he was
in an emotional state to avenge his
friend's rapist but what's not so
settling is that he claimed to go to
quote black areas and that kind of
thought process is still happening in
2019 which just really said now when
asked if he would have the same reaction
if her alleged attacker was white he
said this she just said nourish or Scott
or a bridge or a Lithuanian I would I
know I would have had the same effect I
was trying to kill honor to my stand up
for my dear friend and this this
terrible medieval fashion and I'm a
fairly intelligent guy and that's why it
it can of shocked me when I came down to
earth after having these horrible
feelings luckily no violence occurred
ever now some good did come from Liam
clarifying his story he hopes this is a
teachable moment for others what are you
hoping that people will learn from you
making these statements to talk to open
up to talk about these things you know
we all pretend we're all kind of you
know politically correct well I mean in
this country it's same in my own country
too you sometimes just scratch the
surface and you discover this ratios
embrace ism and bigotry and it's there
there's a lot we all can learn from this
open and honest conversation of course
we will keep you updated on all the
latest with Liam so be sure to subscribe
to all things et until next time guys
I'm at Courtney underscore teza know bye
for now
[Music]
[Applause]